jamais le casse-croûte bégole plus
existe depuis 36 ans encore du comté de
york centre au nord de toronto
multiculturel population vieillissante
revenus moyens le conte est dit-on ici à
une triste particularité ils comptent le
plus grand nombre de rescapés de
l'holocauste
au canada un comté où le vote de la
communauté juive pourrait déterminer le
vainqueur le candidat conservateur mark
hadlow connaît sa clientèle
il sait la courtiser fils de rescapés de
l'holocauste lit-on sur ses pancartes
son appui à israël est affiché partout
jusque sur la boîte aux lettres de son
bureau de comté verrouillé
lors d'une visite en israël on entonne
un cas de le dire qu'il veut absolument
une photo de lui avec steven un peu
devant le mur des lamentations cela
garantirait sa réélection dans son comté
plait-il tactique subtil peut être pas
mais efficace il est près des gens y
cindy cette électrice le ton
conservateur et très direct le ton
conservateur et très affirmatif et sa
pleine certaines parties de la de la
communauté jeu sur l'enjeu d'israël sa
sécurité sa survie sont au coeur des
préoccupations de la communauté juive au
canada le discours très pro-israélien de
steven un peu qui écarte toute critique
d'israël et qui évoque souvent la peur
d'une menace terroriste les liens
étroits qui a tissé avec son homologue
israélien touche des cordes sensibles au
canada
en 2011 une majorité d'électeurs juif
bund le parti libéral et vote
conservateur comme dans le comté de york
centre une première au canada et la
rhétorique conservatrice ne convainc pas
tout le monde
cette militante de gauche reproche aux
conservateurs de manipuler sa communauté
à des fins bassement électorales avec
beaucoup de doigté et ils manipulent
clairement cette peur il manipule aussi
le sentiment de des juifs d'être bon
minoritaire d'être enclavé le vote de la
communauté juive pourrait être
déterminant dans une douzaine de comté
selon le centre consultatif des
relations juives et israéliennes dans
une course aussi serrée
toutes les stratégies sont bonnes ici
joyce n'est que radio canada toronto